darcy and georgie first of all
congratulations
thank you georgie you did great with the
ring
can we see it darcy i actually have it
in connecticut
we're in new york right now doing some
stuff and
i wanted to leave it safe and sound
there because we didn't want to give any
spoilers because
everyone keeps seeing us on the street
and stuff so we uh
thought it was best just to kind of keep
it on the dl until uh
you know it's it's out there more so but
we're really really very grateful i love
the ring it's very close to my heart
and excited to be able to finally talk
about it
so yeah we came here like a few days ago
so i just want to make sure that uh
it was not spoiled yet okay so where are
you all you said you're not in
connecticut where are you we're in new
york
yes okay okay are you there for just
what business
business yeah business and a little
pleasure okay
all right well it's been a long time
coming for you girls so i just want to
know i just want you to
describe the feeling for me when georgie
got on one knee and pulled out that ring
oh yeah it was a very surreal moment
it was a beautiful day um you know there
was some tension in the air from the
night before i know you guys saw a
little teaser there
but uh you know it doesn't hurt to make
you stronger and it was just um
i didn't realize like i think all the
emotions he was having on
when he was quiet kind of like you know
a little a little quiet and a little
little less
open it was making me feel like things
weren't right for some reason so i was a
little caught off guard
but you know we always work on our
issues in the end and when he i think he
was just trying to find the right moment
really
right and when he did it was like so
romantic it threw me off and he had no
clue
and i teared up and he teared up and i
really felt his emotion and it really
made me realize how much he does love me
and just to be free lean back and just
accept it
and that's when i knew it was right and
i said yes
yeah well darcy you said you were
surprised by the proposal
so the queen said georgie how did you
know that this was the right time to
actually pop the question
uh so
i know she's the right one because we've
been talking for a long time even before
we meet
and uh i feel the connection for
the beginning even from the phone and
when we meet
the connection even was stronger and um
after this moving during the quarantine
live together you know
like that's the best uh time to know
someone each other
between each other and to when you leave
with someone for
during the quarantine especially and get
comfortable that's gonna find the the
real person
the real personality so if you can't
survive during the quarantine and i
guess uh you know
we're good to be forever together and we
can't survive
anything else all right well let's get
into the nitty-gritty stuff i have to
ask you something
that fans are just curious about darcy
given the roadblock that you two hit
when you all moved in together when you
found out that georgie was still
legally married what do you say to fans
who are concerned that once again
you're picking the wrong guy right you
know what i mean that was
not an easy situation to go through but
like i said um
taking the risk on him coming to
connecticut and having
you know that opportunity for us to grow
and learn more about each other and
yeah you know it was still a new
relationship and i don't judge him on
having
a separation or going through a divorce
i've been there trust me and it's not
easy so i just want
him to know that i'm by his side i just
wanted everybody to be
you know understanding and the kids for
everybody not to get
like oh well here we go again um you
know
i wear my heart and i sleep i love him
dearly and i just didn't want my kids to
get her or me to get her i just didn't
know how to approach it
i held it in so i didn't really say
anything to have people at that time
i didn't know much about it myself and
the reports are closed
like there was no outcome for you know
for what reasons at that time
and it was confusing but we stood by
each other it's fine we made it work i
was like
how can we proactive what what things
can we do while it's
shut down so you can be prepared it just
was things like that
and um you know i like it he handled it
on his own i wasn't trying like
what are the details i just wanted him
to know you have a support system here
um he did everything on his own i just
wanted him to know that i am here
emotionally to support him and i just
wanted i was holding it and excited
really
you know just moved your quarantine
there's a lot of stuff happening you
know
within like a few weeks period of time
so um
you know stay strong you stay strong
through it well georgie what's the
status of your
your marriage now is the divorce
complete or what can you tell us
yeah i mean um um was very hard to get
divorced because i supposed to get the
divorces actually
um you know before i even had to move to
connect cut everything shut down but
because of the quarantine
everything shut down the courtship down
so it's very very hard and
nothing was awful so just keep keep keep
going and going
and um it was positive yeah i'm very
positive
um but like now currently is that
something that's still a struggle
like have you been able to actually
complete the divorce or no
yeah with the time um we're going to
find out what actually is happening
okay i get that i respect that i just i
have to ask you
um darcy this is this is for you i see
this a lot and i just want you to
somewhat just clear the air a lot of
people assume that you and your sister
are in competition with each other
they think that she got married now
you're rushing
to walk down the aisle i just want to
know what's your response
to that well stacey and i have always
been
close obviously we're twins we share a
unique bond and a lot of things we've
always done is in tandem
you know i don't think it's a
competition people might see it that way
because
people were like twins as having a
competition we only want the best for
each other
so whether she gets married first like
you know originally when we had our kids
and she had her son first then my
daughter it was like
everything was like backed back so i'm
just happy she
she found what she wanted and i'm just
looking for you know the same thing for
me it doesn't have a timeline
but who does what first i think um
that's just the way it seems but that's
not the case we are very supportive of
each other's journey
and we do like similar things i mean
it's kind of ironic how
she's had the two boys i had the two
girls we got married around the same
time originally
and um we went to la at the same time we
started our company together
now you know she had chlorine come then
ironically like you know
you get the force of symptoms we got
divorced on the same day like there's so
many
synchronicities and things that are
ironic the way we live our lives it's
just how it isn't
the only word that we know to do things
and it's kind of subconscious
it just happens that way so yeah tell
people that they get the competition
no that's just how they're seeing stacy
are yeah okay
well georgie what do you say to fans who
are overprotective of darcy
and they're concerned that you might not
be genuine when it comes to this
relationship or you know wanting a
marriage with her
um i can say everything is
good between us and
i have her back i always want to have
her back and i'll
always love her and i'll be there for
her
and um i guess that's why um
the things between us working very well
because we both divorced and we both
uh protecting each other we both have
each other back
and trust each other and that's the most
important for one relationship
um you know to be together to trust each
other to be best friends with each other
to have their bucket with each other and
you know to keep going
so i can tell them i'm there for her and
always that's my personality that's who
i am
and um always will have each other back
i appreciate the fans and their concerns
and stuff it's gotta follow my heart
and and trust him and know that he will
be there
and love me forever the way he says he
does um i could
go through what our relationships and
even in life will go through a lot
i grew up for my age and everything is
with the experience you know
i mean so i feel like i feel and then
knowing him the time
amount the time that i've known him i
definitely feel that sincerity in him
yeah well i know from my personal
experiences
if you like dealing with toxic
relationships
it sometimes makes makes you question
your own judgment like when
when choosing given your unhealthy
relationships that you've had with
jessie and tom
how did you know that georgie's
different how did you know that
he's the one yeah because it's like
i feel like he doesn't try to trigger
that situation to happen it's like yeah
you know you have to go through
you know your life lessons and learn how
to um
you know what you want in a relationship
and in the past it was like i've always
felt like
purposely got triggered they wanted to
trigger me or something like that and
it's like things that
gaslighting and i don't i i don't that
doesn't like
that hurts me and it's like it's like
little red flag flare if i feel like
that's coming against like a little
intuition or feeling it's like you get
upset about it then it could be
something false it could be something
you don't know sometimes it's like
okay well why is this happening you
overthink it i think but he's just like
no that's not the case you know so
i just trusted in the way how his
demeanor is about it he's not
you know he's very calm about it so i'm
able to kind of like not get triggered
yeah because i don't want i don't want
to ever be in like a really
toxic relationship again it's just was
like awful but i've learned
how to heal from that and um you know it
wasn't easy but
i feel like he understands and he's been
through some stuff in the past too so i
feel like
we help each other and know that we'll
always just be there for each other and
we might see things that are always the
way that
they are but then you have to be
comforting to that person like no babe
this is why
you might think it's like this but it's
really not you know yeah i'm the
secretary in the demeanor
the secret it's to be with any woman is
you need to be patient
understanding and compromise all the
time yeah sometimes
even if you know you're wrong you see
you're right
it's that ability to let go of your ego
yeah
yeah i totally get that so darcy do you
have you found peace with your past
relationships now knowing that they led
they've led you to georgie
oh absolutely i am so grateful that i
have taken time to heal
i didn't jump right into this
relationship like people might assume
and um i've stayed strong and i've
worked on myself
and i'm really grateful that he came
into my life at the right time it was
you know time i was
you know enjoying this process of
healing you know
and honoring you know what i deserve the
most
um loving myself and my daughters first
i
came when i least expected it and it you
know it took it seemed like it happened
fast but we did take our babies
we talked for a year before we even we
met very friendly
very friendly very cordial and um you
know i just wasn't ready at the time so
i was always friendly back well i just
when i was ready i just knew and i knew
he was you know he mentioned he was
going to be a mummy miami at the same
time i said yeah why not it's me and it
just it
was like wow how come i get it all that
had to happen
because that time you met was the right
time any other time
i would have met before maybe it was the
wrong time because i wasn't done healing
or whatever else i had to go through and
same for him
the funny part is during this year we
talk we always gonna make different
plans to meet
yeah that never happened because uh i
guess wasn't the right time wasn't the
right time
and miami just happened right away i
don't know it's just yeah
like spontaneous the universe yeah
so has tim or jessie reached out i know
you're probably not looking for it but i
haven't heard anything
no thank you to congrat congratulate you
no i haven't heard from either of them
you know i wish them well i'm just
living my life
and you know you know living the journey
that i'm on and um
i just ready to move on from the past
and you know
you know i haven't heard anything from
them and that's okay do you plan on
changing your last name
i'm gonna keep both so we'll be
hyphenated and be thirsty
well georgie how do you feel being a
step dad like you're about to be a step
back to two teenage
girls how does that feel well um
i feel good because i've been through a
lot even in my teenage age
and you know i go through a lot
moving different cities and moving to
united states living by myself
learn a lot so i know the dollars it's
everything for darcy so
i'm always there for them wherever they
need advice with everything they need
i'll be always there for them with
advices and
anything else yeah he's actually very
he's very old or wise for his years i
think it's because he has
um you know learned a lot at a young age
as well i traveled and
been here for quite a time so he's been
around the world he's
you know has that mindset that i
appreciate and
you know he's a very good asset for us i
feel like
we're like a very strong family unit and
and as partners together like we raise
each other up like
there's no feeling of um you know
you know something more than i do
because of age or anything like that
it's never like okay
you know what i mean and the girls you
know they're teenagers now so he gets it
like
it just flows i don't know how to
describe it but everybody's really happy
and excited for the future yeah well
what are your thoughts on
your own family together is that a
possibility or
you're done you're done with kids well
you know if it's
you know god's in god's hands so
absolutely talk about it and if that
happens we
totally feel blessed and love that
opportunity i don't know
you never know so you haven't talked
about it so it's
not off the
a little georgie well are we going to
get a televised wedding
how do you feel about that are you going
to bring a fall into this special day of
yours
i think it would be absolutely beautiful
to tell by the wedding and
stacy too i think because you know
obviously she got married during um
you know the quarantine and i think she
wants her fairy tale wedding as well
maybe
do a twin style or not we'll see what
the future holds but um
nonetheless i think it'd be very um
beautiful and such a blessing
for um us to share that journey along
with you guys as well
and you know hey she was always better
than one so why not